i've argued before that even though the
right accuses the left of having the
problem of language policing
that actually language policing is just
as big of a problem
on the right if not bigger in the united
states i've argued before that even
though the right accuses the left of
having the problem of overbearing
political correctness that it's actually
just as big of a problem on the right if
not bigger
they just call it something else on the
right and maybe most importantly
even though everybody argues every side
of the issue of political
violence we've heard people take every
position on this issue
the data clearly demonstrate that in the
united states the majority of
politically inspired violence and
domestic terrorism
is done by individuals that would be on
the right of the
political spectrum and one example
exploded this weekend when
right-wing extremist gavin mcinnis gave
a speech in new york city
to members of his group it's a far-right
group that is called the proud boys
which discourages its members from
masturbating or watching porn
so as to motivate them to quote get off
the couch and meet women this is part of
what proud boys
does the southern poverty law center has
said
that um the proud boys requires
recruits get into a physical fight
with an antifa activist at a public
rally sort of like as an initiation
it's sort of like an alt-right fight
club isn't that kind of what you would
that's what it strikes me
make a movie about it well that would be
quite a perverse movie i could assure
you it should be a documentary yeah
uh so we have a bunch of different
videos that have surfaced from this
weekend where apparently
the proud boys came out on such a high
from gavin mcinnes's speech and we're
showing this video to our audience
they came out on on such a high from his
speech at the metropolitan republican
club
that they started kicking and punching
people
all over new york city the video is
total chaos
it's not clear who's doing what police
are now trying to piece it together
there are claims that they're clashing
with left-wing antifa protesters who
were there
in opposition to gavin mcinnis's speech
i guess this is what happens when you
combine
anti-masturbation ideas
with republican in cells rin cells of
course being men who are involuntarily
celibate we've talked about this
they don't want to be celibate but they
seem
unable to stop being celibate if if that
sort of makes sense
here's another video where you'll hear
the word [ __ ] used liberally
as they beat someone this is new york
city okay take a look at this
come on
[Applause]
this is literally a white supremacist
bob mob going around manhattan beating
people up fox news of course
blamed antifa for the entire thing
here's how
how fox news reported this thing the far
left group antifa
strikes again this time at a republican
office in manhattan and the group says
it's just the beginning
trace gallagher is tracking that for us
tonight trace
shannon it was around 1 30 in the
morning when the anti-fascist or antifa
members allegedly vandalized the new
york republican headquarters in new york
city
windows were broken doors spray painted
glue put in locks and handles
and a threatening note was also left
behind saying quote
tonight we put the republican party on
notice in defiance to the policy of mass
misery they have championed the us
government has established
concentration camps around the country
for latino people
shamelessly murders black people and
continues its war machine that has
slaughtered muslim people
with impunity for decades the note goes
on to say their attack is just beginning
and it talks about republicans inviting
a quote
hipster fascist clown to dance for them
a reference to the gop
hosting gavin mcinnis the founder of a
far-right organization called
proud boys who have physically clashed
with antifa protesters
on several occasions today new york
republican chairman ed cox
called on democrats to cease inciting
these attacks
so trace gallagher is talking about
gavin mcinnes
at the time that they show gavin mcinnes
on screen
but he's the guy who is wielding a sword
he's brandishing a sword in the video
and the headline and the story is all
about how antifa is bad
technically trace gallagher did say
gavin mcinnes's name when the video
shows him brandishing the sword
but the entire story is about its antifa
violence
so understand what fox did they show
video of the right-wing leader of the
right-wing group brandishing a huge
sword
but they report that antifa was the
problem at this entire event
yeah and typically fox news will cover
an act of violence committed by antifa
but ignore those committed by the right
yeah this is a situation where
you don't know you don't completely know
who started it but every indication
points the proud boys being the
perpetrators yes and they just
completely flip the script
it's worse it's a lot worse i don't deny
for a second that there were people
not part of the proud boys who were
either inciting or participating in
violence
but this report is totally bogus based
on no evidence and it's directly
contrary to the reports from nypd and to
be clear
i don't defend antifa ever i've never
defended antifa on this program it
appears that some antifa members
were arrested but were released without
charges because it didn't seem that they
actually did anything warranting the
arrest so they were let go
what we know will be taking place here
is a hate crime investigation
into the proud boys and i know i use
this term a lot especially in the lead
up to the midterms
this is what we are fighting that this
is a literal mob
that was running around new york hopped
up on
the rantings of gavin mcinnis beating
people up
we have to vote in november and we have
to vote in a way that is going to move
us away from this stuff being normalized
rather than towards it
today's program is sponsored in part by
title which is a different
kind of music streaming app that fosters
the relationship between
artists and fans and values diversity in
music
they offer unlimited music and video
completely ad-free
you can play your favorite classics you
can discover new artists and most
importantly don't miss their upcoming
benefit concert on october 23rd
this is their fourth annual benefit
concert title x brooklyn it supports
criminal justice reform
if you watch this show you may have
heard me mention that in our
criminal justice system more than 65
percent of prisoners serving life
without parole for non-violent offenses
are african-american one in 15
african-american males is incarcerated
compared to just one in
106 white men which means that
one in three african-american males can
expect to go to prison in their lifetime
all of the net proceeds from title x
brooklyn help to support
charity organizations that want to
reform
this problem including the equal justice
initiative
the innocence project cut 50 and the
concert is going to feature performances
from
lil wayne lauren hill love lauren hill
meek mill anderson pack and more there
will be a free live stream of the entire
show on october 23rd
find out more donate and tune in at
title.com
brooklyn that's l t-i-d-a-l-dot
com forward slash brooklyn